amir is joining us now from where he's
in training camp in colorado springs
thanks for staying up for us amir we
really appreciate it tell me what
happened on that plane
so um i go on the plane and um i was sat
on scene number one a and one b was my
friend who my colleague who was coming
to training with me and um as soon as i
was on the plane i was on the phone i
was on a phone call um the the lady came
over to the edge to a student i said to
me to go up to take to put my phone call
down which i did i put it down didn't
argue i had my mask on everything was
fine
my friend um
must have been drinking some water put
his mask down a little bit had a sip of
water
and the lady then came and said please
you need to put your mask up here it
must it must have been just a little bit
lower than
his um
just below his nose
and um so he fixed that
and then
the plane's moving now so i'm leaning on
the side of the window and if i trying
to fall asleep
and i was on the way to colorado for my
training camp and then the plane some
reason stops
and when it stops um i pull up the
window just to see what happened and um
before you know it the doors open up and
three officers walk in
and and
the estuaries tells us to please can you
leave
and can me and my friend leave
i have done nothing wrong you know i
mean my mask was always up i just think
feel that i got treated so badly um
it was quite embarrassing standing up uh
in front of a full plane
and i think even they were shocked that
you know why are the police in in the
airplane and
why they're taking those two young
boys literally sat right at the front
and um
we got literally taken out and um
they just said that we were not paying
attention to instructions they've given
us they said that my bag one of their
press releases have come and they said
that the bag
my bag was oh and i wasn't listening i
was arguing with them which i never did
i didn't argue with them and
my bag was
in the storage area at the top of the at
the top luggage area
um
i just feel like you know i was just
treated really badly it was a week
after 9 11 and i do feel like you know
things were a little bit tense
but to be picked on
two
asian boys that sat at the front
being pulled out in front of
a full plane it was quite embarrassing
really um
afterwards i spoke to the officers and
they said same thing they go look it's
always an issue with american airlines
and since i've posted it because i had
to post it because i felt like
i was just treated really wrongly and
really badly and um
i mean
just to clarify you feel that you were
asked to get off the plane because of
the color of your skin and it was a week
after 9 11.
i'm i'm not saying that but i think it
might have something to do with that um
maybe people maybe the students and and
the people the stuff didn't feel
comfortable me being their side the
front
i mean
there was no arguments there was no
shouting or anything
uh obviously i'm a very quiet guy and i
respect
when they give the instructions i
respect that and when they told me to
put the phone down which is the only
incident i had when i was on the phone
they said to me to the phone call call
down and we're gonna be leaving soon and
i'm gonna put it down okay i mean
this is what american airlines said um i
just want to put this to you prior to
takeoff on the 18th of september
american airlines flight 700 with
service from newark liberty
international airport to dallas fort
worth returned to the gate to deplane
two customers who reportedly refused to
comply with repeated crew member
requests to stow luggage place cell
phones in airplane mode and adhere to
federal face covering requirements our
customer relations team has reached out
to mr khan to learn more about his
experience so that's their um
understanding of what happened have you
spoken to them since
i spoke to them once when i just got to
colorado um but at that time by that
time i was already banned from and
flying any
uh american airline flight and also i'm
from is at one world which is the
company that
runs american airlines and
when i spoke to the colleague he said
he's gonna go into when i spoke to the
american airlines guy he said to me that
he's going to get back to me obviously
i'm not no response back from the
american airlines team but honestly
speaking i was my phone was on airplane
mode
when i was asked to put the phone down
once that was just once i did put it
down and repeatedly they said that
they were telling me to put my put my
mask up my mask was always up so i'm
sure the plane has
um cameras on on there i don't know if
they do have them on planes but really
they need to check i mean
there was people sat next to us and
there was a little bit of a shock when
the police came in to take us out i mean
we felt like criminals you know they
like like we had done something wrong
the way we were dragged out the plane
and then later on when they recognized
me
when the policeman recognized me took a
selfie with me and obviously the masks
were off then as well and that was
obviously in the airport but i just feel
that
you know um having two police cars
parked outside the airplane like
like with some criminals or like we are
going to do something
i mean it just felt really uncomfortable
and
has definitely put me off i mean
i got to train come quite late um and
you know my trainer was obviously upset
with me coming there late but it is i
mean
yeah i'm just i mean when you were
talking about it i mean on twitter i
mean you did use the hashtag not all
terrorists so you did feel that it was
racially motivated did you
yeah definitely definitely i i'm gonna
stand by that because obviously um
you know
being 9 11 a week before that and then
having two asian boys sat the fun
you know you're gonna think we're these
young boys
um
and and and angry asian as well and
obviously
it makes it a little bit hard but
i hope i'm wrong
um but honestly speaking i had done
nothing wrong um i got just
kicked off a plane for no reason and was
embarrassing
you know we've given american airlines
the right to reply via their statement
um just tell me quickly about
trading colorado springs what's going on
it's really good i mean i've just got
here and i'm doing a couple of a couple
of weeks here um training hopefully i
should be fighting uh
either end of the year or early next
year i wanna
have one or two more fights before i
call it a day and um being up here you
know the altitude is amazing um and
literally it is hard work i mean just to
get your breath
is a lot harder um one round feels like
10 rounds so i'm just enjoying training
and with a new culture over here as well
so he's getting i'm getting to know
what he's like and how he can teach me
and how he can improve my style so
you're saying one or two more fights and
then it's all over for you
yeah i've been in the game a very long
time
i've been in the game i've been on the
scene since i was 17 from the olympic
game from the olympic games in all fall
in in athens 2004
and i am getting on a bit a little bit
now i'm i'm touching 35
35 in december
you're a baba um quick thought before i
let you go about aj getting beat
yeah i mean no one ever expected that
you know i mean joshua is a great
champion and you know i'm sure he's
gonna go back to the drawing board and
see where he made the mistakes and he's
gonna come back stronger i mean look
this is boxing for you you win someone
you lose some but he needs to you know
have his chin up high and you know he's
gonna get a lot of hate which comes with
the territory and he's a huge name in
boxing and
i just hope he comes back stronger and
he gets the rematch against suzuki and
wins his titles back i mean
yeah i mean look um he did seem a little
bit slow in the fight he would get
caught a little bit too much well i'm
sure he can he can fix that and he can
come back stronger okay um you stayed up
late for us we appreciate it get some
sleep and hopefully we'll speak to you
soon thanks a lot
thank you very much thank you